see Mexicans are intelligent people they
understand how to make an ice coffee
unfortunately
Europeans and listen this is with all
due respect you're too [__] dumb in
your
heads to to wrap it around the idea that
if you have cold ice and you put hot
liquid in it then the ice goes away do
you know do you know these can you
explain how you ordered coffee while
we're the austral I had enough F like
this like that chill chill chill
like Cassie out here bro bro I'm telling
you in Australia we went I asked for one
you can tell it he literally just go to
the lady to be like you guys have iced
coffee they be like yep we do and he
goes okay let me ask you this well first
time I don't say that I take their word
for it right I take cuz I asked you a
question do you have iced coffee so I
think what I'm going to get is iced
coffee what they Ser you get a lukewarm
mud I had to pull ak's [__] out of
it made the coffee taste better than
little cre okay and then literally he's
going through like how to make coffee
okay when you guys are making it first
off who makes it and they're like well
are Barista he goes okay bring them out
here Barista comes out he's like okay
when you're making iced coffee yeah are
you making coffee and then chilling it
and then putting into ice or are you
making hot coffee and pouring hot coffee
into ice explain that and then they
would explain what it was and then
depending on the answer he would just we
just take the hot coffee we put it over
the ice okay I go well what happens to
the ice then well it melts well what is
it
now is that an ice coffee no it's not
just on water water down am I am I wrong
to be upset about that yes his first
world problems and shut
up but am I wrong to be upset about that
or
not why are we the only culture that can
wrap our heads around it us and who
Mexicans the greatest facts Mexican's
the greatest and the best cooks they
take all the world's food and then they
make it at good you walk into any
restaurant as a Mexican cook you don't
even question it you don't even you walk
into a Japanese restaurant they got a
Mexican dressed up like a [__]
Japanese guy M you don't question it
that's true Sushi making whatever you
don't question it anywhere else You' be
a little concerned no sushi let's just
call it what it is you walk into a sushi
restaurant you see a black dude with
dreads you eating that sushi I'm curious
actually
that's that could go either way talk to
me like jerk Sushi or some [__] like
that that sh might be fire yeah yeah it
might it might hit or you start going
this is an anime black it might be an
anime black anime black is interesting
you know what that's interesting black
is the wrong example cuz it's so far
from sushi that he might have had this
obsession with sushi and then perfected
the craft to do so I hear what you're
saying anime black we're good yeah he's
a samurai he's just Dosh just for fun
media black 90s out black black dude
wearing Tims missing one of his back
teeth no I'm out of there that's tough
not make it Sushi you can't can't do it
that's I assume Sushi chefs went to like
a lot of training they really learn if
you're Mexican I'm like they don't need
train matter you figured it out they
don't need it they're born with training
it's just in them yeah if there's no
hint to Yellow like it's bad Sushi can I
ask you a question anytime you've hired
someone who of
Mexican uh excuse me background for any
job have you asked for a qualification
never no and did you know it would be
done well yeah
yeah y they're the only people they're
the best people that you don't need to
know if they're qualified for the job to
pay them to do it they're always
qualified they figure it out figure it
out ice
coffee on a Sprint 40 meter dash run a
65 to get you coffee not a a centiliter
spilled is that an amount I don't think
is it milliliters got to be centiliters
wow I've never heard of a centiliter
welcome to sister all my life yeah a
kiler that's a thing no oh that's true
that's true it's just a leader distance
right I don't think you could do that
are there centiliters miles yeah they're
both of course they're centiliters CL
bro is that a thing yeah it is okay I I
anyway yeah um none of us spill they're
the best I don't know where we're going
what we're talking about how was
Australia oh yeah Mara was Australia
first you loved it you had the best time
he asked you and you told him what he of
M I said Andrew how the [__] was it yeah
[__] here we go let's let's say
couple things with Australia couple
things with Australia one serious answer
and I don't want us to be serious that
much on the Pod but like coolest thing
ever going to another country and doing
Arenas like just [__] so surreal
awesome where the Australian Open is is
crazy bro it was just insane these
venues like it was just [__] unbel
unable so that was really awesome and
the support out there was incredible
yeah lot a lot of people it was just
like it was so [__] cool so you
didn't even realize how big it was there
there were certain places we walked into
he looked at me he's like wait we're
doing an arena yeah I didn't I was like
how did you not know I didn't even know
I didn't even I yeah we shouldn't have
played paddle for three hours before
this show yeah I mean we played paddle
in every [__] City that had a paddle
court but it was a it was just so
awesome thank you guys so much for
coming out and those shows were just
amazing and uh and now yeah stop being
serious yeah no no more serious um they
[__] love Coke out there I've never
been offered Coke more than when we were
in Australia and I've gone to Burning
Man four times yeah the amount of coke
offered would I would say
10x what has happened to me and burning
man wow W every the co cocaine is where
are they getting it from I don't know
but that [__] is
expensive Mexicans probably the best C I
bet you they do make the best Coke do
they not know about fentol in Australia
like how are they so brave does no one
die of fentol I I maybe it hasn't hit
there yet yeah hasn't hit there if
they're buying shitty Coke then they
don't care they don't give they
acknowledge it it's shitty right off the
top they're just like yeah it's like 20%
pure 30% or something like that like
they but they love Coke and they love
boring
questions that's their favorite thing
get as coked up as possible and ask you
the most mundane [__] you've ever heard
in your life like what so uh you like
food
like that's a normal question coked out
of their [__] mind
yeah and then you answer it and then you
answer it and then another one yeah you
probably do more coke of it's shitty
though I mean just keep doing it who
cares the high goes quickly like yeah
20% I'm not going to overdose it's too
shitty I just keep doing it maybe shitty
Coke is the way to go this pure Coke
it's a problem dude you think I think
you need shitty Coke you just keep doing
it no risk of oding it's probably
cheaper we're just going what about the
other ship that's in it that's that's
kind of the ca kills and [__] you might
o on some of the other ship spos did
those and say by the Bel she was mostly
okay yeah creatine they put in theree
that's awesome that's also great that's
yeah Mark did that fentol that's what
people die from yeah but not not in
Australia apparent we don't know we
don't know we don't know but yeah no it
was it was fire just to go out there to
an AR like yeah you just always think
about that at least in the beginning of
your career like yeah one day I'm going
to do Arenas and then we're in another
country doing Arenas yeah was crazy and
you're just like wow like there's
statues of basketball players outside
it's crazy yeah should like I didn't
even know they played basketball in
[__] Australia like go to priz pi.com
use a promo code Schultz they'll match
your initial entry of $100 up to that
$100 so you put 100 they're going to
match up to 100 exactly that's beautiful
you said that better than me now listen
we in this together we're Team okay we
are teams go to priz pick.com get that
100% deposit match up to $100 with the
promo code Schultz SZ you got this okay
now let's get back to the sh